♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING, AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
HOLY SMOKES THERE IS A LOT
GOING ON IN THIS COUNTRY
RIGHT NOW.
WE ARE GOING TO DO OUR BEST
OVER THE NEXT HOUR TO
EXPLAIN WHAT IS HAPPENING
AND WHAT IT MEANS.
WE'RE LEARNING OURSELVES IN
A LOT OF CASES THE ANSWER TO
BOTH OF THOSE QUESTIONS.
SO FOR ALMOST THREE YEARS
THE LEADERSHIP OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IN CONGRESS
RESISTED CALLS FROM ITS
POLITICALLY INFLAMED BASE TO
IMPEACH PRESIDENT TRUMP.
POLLS SHOWED LITTLE SUPPORT
FOR IMPEACHMENT AMONG ACTUAL
VOTERS.
THEY WERE SKEPTICAL OF IT.
OLDER MEMBERS IN CONGRESS
LIKE NANCY PELOSI REMEMBER
WELL WHAT HAPPENED THE LAST
TIME THE OPPOSITION PARTY
IMPEACHED A SITTING
PRESIDENT.
REPUBLICANS DID THAT, YOU
WILL REMEMBER, BACK IN 1998.
AND IN THE END, THE ONLY
WINNER IN THAT SAGA WAS BILL
CLINTON HIMSELF.
HE WAS SUPPOSEDLY DISGRACED
BUT, IN FACT, IF YOU LOOKED
AT THE NUMBERS, HE WAS
POLITICALLY MUCH STRONGER
THAN HE HAD BEEN BEFORE HE
WAS IMPEACHED.
PELOSI, AND NOT FOR NO
REASON, TOLD COLLEAGUES SHE
WORRIED THAT SHE WORRIED
IMPEACHING DONALD TRUMP
MIGHT JUST GET HIM
REELECTED.
UP UNTIL JUST LAST WEEK
IMPEACHMENT SEEMED LIKE A
FADING PROSPECT AND THEN
SUDDENLY OUT OF NOWHERE IT
SEEMS A LITTLE FANFARE AND
LITTLE EXPLANATION
EVERYTHING SEEMED TO CHANGE.
TONIGHT JUST A FEW HOURS AGO
PELOSI ANNOUNCED THAT
IMPEACHMENT PROCEEDINGS ARE,
IN FACT, UNDERWAY.
FULL STEAM AHEAD.
>> I CAN SAY WITH AUTHORITY
THAT TRUMP ADMINISTRATION'S
ACTIONS UNDERMINE BOTH OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY AND OUR
INTELLIGENCE.
THE ACTIONS OF THE TRUMP
PRESIDENCY REVEALS
DISHONORABLE FACTS OF THE
PRESIDENT'S RETRAIL OF OUR
OATH OF OFFICE.
FEE FRAIL MUCH THE NAUERT
AND BETRAYAL OF OUR
ELECTION.
THEREFORE TODAY, I'M
ANNOUNCING THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES COMING FORTH
WITH AN OFFICIAL IMPEACHMENT
INQUIRY.
I'M DIRECTING OUR SIX
COMMITTEES TO PROCEED WITH
THEIR INVESTIGATIONS UNDER
THAT UMBRELLA OF IMPEACHMENT
INQUIRY.
THE PRESIDENT MUST BE HELD
ACCOUNTABLE, NO ONE IS ABOVE
THE LAW.
>> Tucker: THE PEOPLE WHO
SOLD OUT YOUR COUNTRY TO
CHINA ARE CONCERNED
PRESIDENT TRUMP BETRAYED
AMERICA SOMEHOW.
AS OF THIS MOMENT PELOSI'S
PARTY SEEMS TO AGREE THEY
ARE BEHIND HER, MOSTLY.
AS CONGRESSMAN JOHN LEWIS OF
GEORGIA EXPLAINED, WORKING
TO REMOVE AN ELECTED
PRESIDENT JUST A YEAR BEFORE
A DEMOCRATIC ELECTION IS, IN
FACT, SOMEHOW A DEFENSE OF
DEMOCRACY OR SOMETHING LIKE
THAT.
WATCH I BELIEVE I TRULY
BELIEVE THE TIME TO BEGIN
IMPEACHMENT PROCEEDINGS
AGAINST THIS PRESIDENT HAS
COME.
TO DELAY OR TO DO OTHERWISE
WOULD BETRAY THE FOUNDATION
OF OUR DEMOCRACY.
>> Tucker: UM-HUH.
ARE YOU CONFUSED YET?
IF SO, WE DON'T BLAME YOU.
IF YOU LEFT TOWN FOR THE
WEEKEND YOU MIGHT BE
WONDERING WHAT THE HELL IS
GOING ON, EXACTLY.
IMPEACHMENT?
FOR YEARS THEY TOLD YOU
TRUMP WAS GOING TO BE
COLLUDING WITH RUSSIA,
SPYING FOR PUTIN.
THEN IT TURNED OUT HE DIDN'T
DO THAT THE STORY EVAPORATED
INTO DUST AND SEEMED TO BLOW
AWAY.
THEN JUST A FEW DAYS AGO
THEY WERE GRUMBLING ABOUT
IMPEACHMENT AGAIN AND THEY
DRAGGED COREY LEWANDOWSKI
REMEMBER HIM BROUGHT UP TO
CAPITOL HILL TO MAKE THEIR
CASE.
THAT DIDN'T GO WELL AT ALL.
>> I SIMPLY ASK YOU IS IT
CORRECT AS REPORTED IN THE
MUELLER REPORT ON JUNE 19TH,
2017, YOU MET ALONE IN THE
OVAL OFFICE WITH THE
PRESIDENT?
>> COULD YOU READ THE EXACT
LANGUAGE OF THE REPORT, SIR.
I DON'T HAVE IT AVAILABLE TO
ME.
>> I DON'T THINK I NEED TO
DO THAT AND I HAVE LIMITED
TIME.
DID YOU MEET ALONE WITH THE
PRESIDENT ON THAT DATE.
>> CONGRESSMAN, I WOULD LIKE
YOU REFRESH MY MEMORY BY
PROVIDING THE REPORT SO I
CAN FOLLOW ALONG.
>> YOU DON'T HAVE A COPY
WITH YOU.
>> I DON'T HAVE A COPY OF
THE REPORT, CONGRESSMAN.
>> YOU DON'T HAVE AN
INDEPENDENT RECOLLECTION OF
WHETHER YOU MET WITH THE
PRESIDENT ON THAT DATE.
>> CONGRESSMAN, I'M JUST
TRYING TO FIND IN THE
MUELLER REPORT WHERE IT
STATES THAT.
>> WELL, HAVE YOU IN FRONT
OF YOU, I GAVE YOU THE PAGE
NUMBER.
>> WHERE ON PAGE 90 IS IT
SIR?
>> MR. CHAIRMAN YOU HAVE
CLOCK.
>> NO I STILL CLOCK.
>> IT DIDN'T TAKE MUCH FOR
CHAIRMAN NADLER TO COLLAPSE
ON C-SPAN PRETTY
EMBARRASSING YOU THEY WOULD
DECIDE TO RUN A REAL
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN IN
2019 AND TRY TO BEAT TRUMP
THAT WAY.
HAS TO BE MORE EFFECTIVE
THAN NOW.
AS OF THIS MORNING DONALD
TRUMP'S APPROVAL RATING IS
THE HIGHEST IT HAS BEEN
SINCE INAUGURATION.
DEMOCRATS DON'T WANT TO WAIT
UNTIL THE NEXT ELECTION.
THEY WILL DON'T WANT TO WAIT
UNTIL NOVEMBER.
POLITICS TAKES TOO LONG AND
LEAVES TOO MUCH TO CHANCE.
THE RISK TO DEMOCRACY IS
VOTERS MIGHT NOT AGREE WITH
YOU.
HILLARY CLINTON LEARNED THAT
THE HARD WAY IN 2016 ONE
THINGS DEMOCRATS DON'T WANT
TO DO IS THAT.
BRINGS US TO THE LATEST
QUESTION OF IMBEEVMENT.
WHAT EXACTLY IS THIS ABOUT?
>> SORRY TO LAUGH IN THE
MIDDLE OF THIS.
WE SPENT ALL DAY TRYING TO
FACE G FIGURE OUT WHAT IS
THE IMPEACHMENT STORY?
IT'S ABOUT UKRAINE.
IT'S LESS THAN A WEEK OLD.
YOU MIGHT BE FORGIVEN FOR
NOT UNDERSTANDING THE
PRESIDENT BE IMPEACHED FOR A
STORY THAT THE DEMOCRATS
LITERALLY CAN'T EXPLAIN
WHETHER A DID THE PRESIDENT
DO WRONG WE WILL TELL YOU
THE CASE THEY ARE MAKING.
TELL YOU IT'S CONFUSING AND
NOT ALL THAT INTERESTING.
HERE'S WHAT THEY ARE SAYING.
THEY ARE SAYING IN A PHONE
CALL WITH THE PRESIDENT OF
UKRAINE, THE PRESIDENT
THREATENED TO DELAY A
400-MILLION-DOLLAR MILITARY
AID PACKAGE TO UKRAINE
UNLESS UKRAINIAN GOVERNMENT
AGREED TO INVESTIGATE
POSSIBLE CRIMINAL ACTIVITY
INVOLVING JOE BIDEN'S SON.
WHY JOE BIDEN'S SON?
WELL, FOR FIVE YEARS JOE
BIDEN'S SON, IT TURNS OUT,
WAS PAID HUNDREDS OF
THOUSANDS OF DOLLARS PER
YEAR TO SERVE ON THE BOARD
OF THE UKRAINIAN GAS
COMPANY.
WHY WITH JOE BIDEN'S SON BE
ON THE BOARD OF UKRAINIAN
GAS COMPANY?
HE HAD NO EXPERIENCE IN THE
ENERGY BUSINESS.
HE DIDN'T SPEAK THE RELEVANT
LANGUAGE.
HE HAD APPARENTLY  NO
EXPERIENCE WHATSOEVER IN THE
REGION.
TURNS OUT AT THAT VERY
MOMENT JOE BIDEN WAS
PRESIDENT OBAMA'S POINT MAN
FOR UKRAINE.
OH, SO IN A CERTAIN POINT
DURING THIS SAGA, THE
COMPANY IN QUESTION WAS
INVESTIGATED.
AND THEN IN 2016, THE
UKRAINIAN PROSECUTOR
OVERSEEING THAT
INVESTIGATION WAS FIRED,
APPARENTLY HE WAS FIRED
UNDER PRESSURE FROM THEN
VICE PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN.
NOW, TO THE LAYMAN, THAT
LOOKS A LOT LIKE CORRUPTION.
WHAT DOES THAT HAVE TO DO
WITH THE PRESIDENT BEING
IMPEACHED IN THE ACCUSATION
IS THE PRESIDENT TRUMP
SUGGESTED THAT THAT SKETCHED
INVESTIGATION
SQVESTIGATION
SQUESTIGATION
SQUELCIGATION
SQUELCHEATION
SQUELCHEDTION
SQUELCHEDINON
SQUELCHEDINVESTIGATION SERVED A
SECOND LOOK.
DEMOCRATS SAY THAT
SUGGESTION WAS AN
IMPEACHABLE OFFENSE.
ARE YOU FOLLOWING THIS?
OF COURSE THEY THERE ARE
PLENTY OF OTHER REASONS THAT
THE U.S. MIGHT NOT WANT TO
SEND $400 MILLION TO UKRAINE
IT'S A NOTORIOUS CORRUPT
COUNTRY FOR ONE THING WHAT
DO WE GET OUT OF IT FOR
ANOTHER.
SENDING MILITARY AID TO THE
UKRAINE MAY PLEASE NEOCONS
ON CNN BILL CRYSTAL IS FOR
IT.
GREATLY INCREASES THE WITH
RUSSIA NUCLEAR CONFLICT
POTENTIALLY.
WHAT'S THE POINT OF THAT
EXACTLY.
NOBODY HAS BOTHERED TO
EXPLAIN WHY SENDING
400 MILLION IN MILITARY AID
TO UKRAINE IS IN THE
INTEREST OF THE UNITED
STATES.
THEY HAVEN'T EVEN THOUGHT TO
EXPLAIN THAT.
THEY ARE TOO BUSY YELLING
ABOUT IMPEACHMENT AND THEY
ARE DOING IT WITH ALL THE
HYSTERICAL INTENSITY THAT
HAS BECOME THE HALLMARK OF
THE MODERN LEFT.
THEY HAVE A LOT OF ENERGY.
TOO BAD NONE OF IT IS
FOCUSED ON THE COUNTRY'S
REAL PROBLEMS.
THERE ARE A LOT OF THEM.
WE DON'T WANT TO GO THROUGH
THE SAME LITANY AGAIN.
WE WILL A COUPLE WORTH
MENTIONING.
NATIONAL DEBT IS EXPLODING
THAT INCLUDES CREDIT CARD
DEBT.
PERSONAL DEBT AT HIGHEST
EVER MEASURED.
WE HAVE A WAR IN AFGHANISTAN
WE CAN'T SEEM TO WIN OR END.
OUR TOWNS OUTSIDE THE BIG
CITIES ARE BEING
DISSEMINATED AND DEFECATED
BY OPIOIDS AND SUICIDE.
IF YOU HAVEN'T BEEN THERE
TAKE A LOOK YOURSELF
BASICALLY OPEN BORDER WITH
34EBGS CO.
TECH COMPANIES TRYING TO
CONTROL OUR FREE SPEECH.
IN MANY WAYS OUR COUNTRY IS
ON THE WRONG TRACK AND
PEOPLE KNOW IT.
EVERYBODY KNOWS IT DEMOCRATS
AND REPUBLICANS.
INSTEAD OF TRYING TO FIX ANY
OF THAT.
DEMOCRATS WANT TO SPEND THE
NEXT YEAR EXPLAINING AND
THEY PLAN, TO EXPLAINING WHY
IT WAS PERFECTLY FAIR FOR
JOE BIDEN'S NE'ER DO WELL
SON TO GET 600 GRAND A YEAR
FROM RUSSIAN OLIGARCHS.
THAT'S TOTALLY FINE BUT
SOMEHOW CRIMINAL FOR DONALD